ثلاثه
جنيه
كثير كثير
جدا
كانت دائما
معرفه
المدرسه
الاوائل
[موسيقى]
لكن
الاجابات الاسئله اللي كانت في ذلك
اميره
اقرا كتب
في مجالات متعد
ده
وصلت
جميله كثير وكذلك حتى لو تيجي امي
يعني مثلا الرياضه الرياضه
القراءه حديثه
[موسيقى]
اغنيه
لانه
اشخاص
من الاردن
مشكلتي الحاجات ديه ما هي مشكله خ
ضره ولا مهارات بينما فشلت الحديثين
وفقا لما
تراه من الاحيان كنت
باحبها فيديو
اطلع من الاوليه
منين من امريكا
ليه لانه حقيقه احنا في السينما يكون
اكتسوم جايين ننزل فيديوهات وعاملين جدا
اكثر اي واحده
يعني ليه لان احنا بيكون متفقين على
الحياه 50 ما يبقا احنا الكلام ده لبنانيه
من الطاقه
جدا جدا جدا
واحنا نعيش
حياتنا
على التسويق على اساس تتوقع منا اللي
بعد
كل ده
حقيقي
هل ناخذ ضحايا المجتمع
حريقه جدا
طريقه تعاملنا ما عندي مشكله
[تصفيق]
المدرسه
يا اما اختار الطريقه الثانيه
في القطيع
السلف
ابتسم واقوي
الورثه
اصبحت اكثر ثقه
كبيره
جديده جدا
الشعور الصعوبه هاطلع من الاحتياديه يعني
ما كنت عارفه
[تصفيق]
امريكيه اصبح
ولو فرد واحد في السماء
طيب بديت ازعل الحادثه لكن
المشكله جديده
القوه والجماع
كبيره
نوال الكويت الله عواطف ما في نهائي
كانت الدنيا
اكاديمي
وهي واحده من الحاجات
القصير
في العالم
مقفول
قلبي تعقلون
لا تجعل سلاح المشاعر ولا تجعل زينه
وشمالك
يحلل مع هذا
الاسئله المغربي
ولدت المزرعه
من
الارض
ماذا قدم الامم الا بكنيسه الحياه
ولا التعادل
يا ولد جميله بان تكوني راضيه
من حاله الروحانيه بان تكوني تلك التي
ابتعد
ت عائشه
والحكم
الوقوامع لهم ويعام
والاجتهاد والمستمر
[تصفيق]
بعد حزب الله سبحانه وتعالى
الحمد لله
الذي فهمت من اخر زوج
يه وليست مجانيه الذهبيه ليس
معفنه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وكل واحد فينا احنا كبشب عنده تحقيق نعيش
الحياه
اجمل النجاح
يعني
فداليات
التامهيم الصحيحه
ليه لانه كل واحد فينا عباره
عن كل واحد مسؤول عن عالم حذيفه امام
المسؤوليه
صح
اوكي لان احنا العالمي المستوى من الوعي
والسلام واليقين
او المحبه
هنشوف العالم
اذا تغيير جدا جدا
[موسيقى]
2 6 8
[تصفيق]